your family is from Saint Lucia
and you
born there here no I was born here okay
what brought them here
same as everybody else my dad came for
the work he comes over to test the
waters a bit sent for my mum they kept a
lot of their bad experiences away from
us obviously which a lot of I feel a lot
of West Indian parents did and their
their way of letting us know it's going
to be tough was you've got to work twice
as hard which is a line you'll hear from
every Caribbean
descendant twice as hard to get half as
far I was brought up at a time when
you know I'm from the East End of London
I'm a cockney black man
but I'm a cockney
I'm an eastender
it's the 75th anniversary
and I don't want to say it out loud but
I will it could be the last time we
truly celebrate windrust properly
the 100th with where around still Trevor
you know but there's that disconnect I
think
between a lot of young people in the
Caribbean I just don't think we should
we should assume that we should all
that every kid who's a descendant of
Windrush should be into Windrush